moi il ya un moment de ma vie qui m'a
marqué ça a été la fran la coupe du
monde france 98
c'est un moment qui pour moi est super
important parce que ça a été pas mon
premier déclic mais quelque chose qui
m'a toujours accompagné qui m'a dit
voilà tu as envie de briller tu as envie
de réussir à gagner des médailles d'or
ben voilà inspire toi de cette équipe de
france 98 qui qui qui s'est entraîné dur
qui a été soudé et qui a été au bout de
deux de soi même et qui a battu les
meilleurs
[Musique]
le fait que ce soit passé en france à
paris que j'ai vu le quart des bleus
passent et que j'ai été à l'arc de
triomphe les voir quand il faisait leur
tour d'honneur c'est des choses que je
n'oublierai jamais et et après coup moi
quand j'ai commencé à gagner mais
compétition que j'ai eu cette notoriété
que j'ai pu croiser échanger ou devenu
ami avec certains c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire et c'est des choses qui
m'ont qui m'ont aidé dans ma vie de
jeune sportif c'est les champions qu'ils
sont qu'ils ont fait à des jeunes comme
moi et ils ont moi c'est ça a été la
première des cultes dans le sport ça m'a
donné envie mais aussi de décrire mon
histoire c'est la rencontre avec ce
professeur qui m'a fait naître dans ce
sport et performer dans ce sport promet
moment où j'ai fait du judo c'était avec
mon frère on a découvert ce sport
ensemble
et bah je crois qu'on a tous les deux a
aimé on a tout de suite aimé parce qu'on
a on est tombé sur un futur professeur
ça à l'impérieux je crois que c'est l'un
des meilleurs entraîneurs que j'ai
jamais eu
et jusqu'à maintenant même si c'est mon
petit professeur quand j'ai un doute je
demande de m'en expliquer une certaine
certaines choses et je n'oublie pas quoi
et
je crois quoi si si j'ai réussi à être
champion au judo c'est en partie grâce à
lui parce qu'il m'a fait aimer ce sport
[Musique]
perdre après dix ans de
d'invincibilité
je me dis c'est pas si mal mais c'est
surtout voilà je me dis juste que j'ai à
préparer c'est pas plus mal que ça
m'arrive maintenant comme ça je sais qu
est-ce que ce qui me manque pour être au
top et surtout bas ça m'enlève
beaucoup de poids sur les épaules je le
dis que ça sera ça en moins parce que
tokyo jeux olympiques médaille d'or
annoncé voit le bout voilée par le
moment où voilà je me
voilà je comprends que j'ai perdu ben
est tout simple attaque je me fais
concret donc très vite on comprend que
voilà ce sera pas pour cette fois
je me plie au début c'est le non pas ici
pas à paris j'ai adressé ben ouais ça
arrivait faut faire avec et comprendre
très influent non pourquoi ça va arriver
on doit se servir de ça pour rebondir
on doit se servir de ça pour aller
chercher puisé cette force pour gagner
la prochaine compétition prendre sa
revanche et surtout aller au bout de son
projet qui pour moi je veux un tuyau
tokyo
[Musique]
il ya ce moment dans le confinement ou
way
où je me dis bon ben je laisse tomber
quoi
et à ce moment où ma femme me dit non je
peux pas laisser tomber parce que ta
fille aimerait bien de te voir
donc ouais ça me remet aux chiefs
amoureux booth est donc dans la tête
c'est jeter pas entrer toutes ces années
pour arrêter aussi près un an de toute
façon c'est quoi pourra sortir de
nouveau on s'adapte c'est ça aussi la
grande faculté à sortir des eaux sait
s'adapter donc noël on continue le
moment du confinement pour moi ça a été
une pause dans ma vie il pose parce que
ça a permis d'être avec mes enfants de
les découvrir de les voir grandir dès ce
matin midi soir avec eux de me découvrir
aussi un peu plus dans mon dans ma
période d'entraînement
et puis voilà d'être concentré se
recentre et se prend en main aussi parce
que en général avec mes entraîneurs qui
gère tout quoi la gérer mes séances tout
ma récupération paquin et vraiment ça a
été une période marquante de ma vie mais
extraordinaire
[Musique]